hola hoy tengo muchas ganas de que me
ayudes a resolver este ejercicio que
saqué de nuestra página de internet el
cual diste sea fx igual a x el seno de
px
isea ld x la línea lización local de f
en a igual a 2 ojo esto nos va a servir
cual es la regla para el de x y bueno
justo por acá copie el mismo ejercicio
pero aquí lo tenemos en nuestro blog de
notas así que con esto lo podemos
trabajar lo primero que se me ocurre que
podemos hacer es bueno porque no nos
preguntamos por la gráfica de fx así que
para esto han déjame traer aquí a dos
ejes
voy a poner que este es uno de mis ejes
ok y por acá voy a suponer que tengo
otro de mis ejes ok de lujo y bueno lo
que me preguntan es cuál es la línea
lización local df en igualados y
recuerda que cuando te dan un valor para
bueno pues recuerda que es la convención
para decir cuál es la aproximación local
o cuál es la aproximación
alrededor de este valor el valor de x
aproximado para este valor así que para
eso aún continuamos la gráfica estos van
a ser mis ejes ok este es mi eje x ok
este es mi eje y bueno aquí me voy a
tomar el cero aquí voy a tomarme al 1 ok
por acá al 2 ok por acá me voy a tomar
al 3 y de hecho nosotros queremos ver
cuál es la regla para el de x aquí
cuando avale 2 por aquí vamos a estar
pero para eso primero déjenme hacer un
esbozo de lo que está pasando
vamos a tomar este color y bueno fíjate
que si x vale 0 0 por lo que sea rápido
podemos ver que aquí empieza o pasa por
el 0 muy bien ahora si nosotros nos
fijamos en esta función el seno de pi x
cuando x es un número entero
bueno pues recuerda que el seno de un
entero por pin eso siempre es 0 por lo
tanto sea lo que valga es entero siempre
que tengamos a x como un número entero
esto me va a quedar 0
es decir que en uno me va a quedar cero
ok en dos me va a quedar dos por el seno
de dos pero el seno de 20 por 20 ok
en 3 nos va a quedar también serón
etcétera esto parece estar muy extraño
pero qué te parece si pensamos en un
medio si nosotros pensamos en un medio
que es lo que va a pasar en este valor
bueno pues ya te cuenta que el seno de
pi medios o el seno de pi medios ese sí
lo sabemos es 11 por un medio bueno pues
eso me va a quedar un medio así que si
por aquí tengo el valor de 1 ok
entonces voy a tomar el valor de un
medio es decir por acá va a estar mi
función y bueno ya va agarrando forma
esta función va a ser algo más o menos
así ahora si nos fijamos por ejemplo en
tres medios bueno nosotros sí sabemos
cuánto vale el seno de tres medios de pi
el seno de tres medios de pi es menos
uno menos uno por tres medios bueno eso
es menos tres medios así que déjenme
bajar un poco más esta gráfica ok vamos
a bajar un poco más este eje
bueno pues supongamos que está menos uno
por aquí tenemos a menos uno ok entonces
al menos tres medios esto va a estar
como por aquí ok del lujo entonces esto
va a bajar hasta acá
ok va a tocar este punto algo va a pasar
y después va a subir hasta dos dónde va
a tomar otra vez el valor de cero veamos
un valor más qué pasa si nosotros nos
fijamos en cinco medios es decir en 2.5
qué va a pasar en cinco medios
bueno pues date cuenta que va a pasar
algo similar el seno de cinco medios de
pib
bueno pues recuerda que esto es 11 por 5
medios va a ser 5 medios por aquí está
el 2 o keith entonces por acá va a pasar
mi función ok
más o menos por aquí y entonces esta
función se empieza a abrir cada vez más
y después va a llegar de nuevo al 3 en 0
ahora lo que nosotros queremos es la
línea lización de esta función cuando a
vale 2 por lo tanto nos vamos a fijar
qué es lo que pasa justo aquí cerca de
este valor y para no olvidarnos pongamos
que están antes
igual a efe efe de equis y bueno
nosotros lo que queremos es la línea
lización y déjame ponerlo con este color
la línea lización local ok alrededor de
a igual a todos eso es muy importante no
voy a fijar alrededor de este valor es
decir que aquí tengo a igualados y
entonces voy a buscar la línea lización
alrededor de este punto que bueno
esencialmente tenemos que encontrar la
pendiente de la recta tangente a esta
función en este punto es decir a en el
punto 2
efe de 2 y para eso imagínate que aquí
me tomo am la recta tangente ok y justo
ésta es la que vamos a buscar voy a
decir que esta es mi recta tangente que
estoy buscando es decir ye igual a l de
x
ld x pero lo padre es que lo vamos a
escribir de una forma en la que vamos a
poder tener una aproximación lineal
alrededor de este punto dicho de otra
manera para algún valor de x alrededor
de este valor y por lo tanto si queremos
saber cómo escribir a esta lx lo voy a
poner aquí
ld x como la encontramos bueno pues el
de x va a ser igual a efe de a es decir
lo que vale f en este punto justo este
valor que nosotros tenemos aquí este
valor que nosotros tenemos aquí ya esto
le sumamos la pendiente que nos da a
esta recta tangente en ese mismo punto
es decir la pendiente de esta recta de
amarillo ya esto hay que multiplicarlo
por x menos ha dicho otra manera por la
diferencia de el valor que queremos
encontrar la aproximación cercano a este
valor de amd es que eso está padrísimo
porque por ejemplo si tú te fijas en
algún valor
supongamos este que está cercano 2
a 2.25 que está muy cercano a dos o
cualquier valor que tengamos en esta
gráfica vamos a poder encontrar una
aproximación utilizando esta idea de l
de x es decir nos fijamos en el valor
que tenemos aquí y después a esto habrá
que multiplicarlo por la pendiente de
esta recta aunque es el cambio en x a
comparación del cambio en james ok y nos
da precisamente una 7 aproximación ok
para este valor en este caso am
supongamos que es este punto entonces
nos va a dar esta aproximación ahora
entre más cercanos tenemos el punto
mejor va a ser nuestra aproximación pues
bien vamos a trabajar a ld x y a l de x
la tenemos que sacar de esta forma así
que am bueno recuerda que vamos a
reemplazar aa por 2 ok por qué tenemos
este valor ok entonces a esto lo voy a
reemplazar por 2 ya esto lo voy a
reemplazar por 2 y que me queda bueno
que el de x es igual ok
efe 2 ok eso es lo mismo que 2 por el
seno ok de 2
ok ahorita vemos cuántos esto aunque ya
sabemos que esto es 0 + efe prima de 2 y
para eso sería muy bueno calcular cuánto
es f prima de x ok
bueno pues date cuenta que aquí tenemos
una multiplicación de funciones entonces
su derivada que va a ser primero hay que
derivar a una de estas dos funciones
voy a derivar a x la derivada de x es 1
y me queda 1 por la otra función es
decir el seno ok de pi por x de pi por x
ok ya esto habrá que sumarle ok ahora
voy a poner la otra función del cual x y
voy a derivar la segunda la derivada del
seno de pi por x es lo mismo que la
derivada del seno es el coseno el coste
no debe x pero recuerda que también hay
que multiplicar por la derivada de
adentro así que eso me va a quedar y
veces y veces
ok por el seno de pi x para derivar esto
hay que utilizar solamente la regla de
la cadena y bueno recordar la
multiplicación de funciones ahora si
queremos calcular
efe ok prima de 2 esto cuánto va a ser
bueno el seno de 2 pib
eso es 0 entonces me va a quedar 0 + y
aquí me quedaría dos veces spin porque x
vale 2 ok por el consenso de 2 pib pero
el coche no de 2 pib ahora sabemos que
esto es 1 por lo tanto esto se siente
sencillamente 2002
ok entonces lo voy a poner aquí 2 pin ok
que multiplica a x menos 2 de lujo y
ahora sí si nosotros queremos encontrar
a él de x de una manera explícita bueno
pues me va a quedar el seno de 2 pin eso
es 00 por dos ok eso es 0 + 2 pib ok por
x2
p x x 2 x x menos 2 y si te das cuenta
es justo esta opción que tenemos aquí
esta sería nuestra respuesta correcta es
más déjame ponerlo con un color un poco
más llamativo y es que ya está de lujo
porque teniendo esta expresión de aquí
podemos calcular una aproximación de lo
que nosotros queramos por ejemplo si
quisiéramos calcular una aproximación
para efe de 2 + 0.1 ok bueno pues esto
es aproximadamente igual y si te das
cuenta si nosotros quisiéramos calcular
esto en esta función se ve bastante
difícil techo hasta ponerlo en
calculadora se ve un poco complicado
pero ahora ya tenemos una buena
aproximación utilizando el de x podemos
decir que esto es aproximadamente 2 pin
ok que multiplican a y bueno aquí tengo
2 + 0.1 menos 2 bueno pues eso es lo
mismo que 0.1 0.1 utilizando esta
aproximación local que tenemos justo
alrededor de este punto y es que ya está
de lujo porque bueno 2 x 0.1 y esto es
lo mismo que punto 2 por pin 0.2 por pi
y bueno ya multiplicar 0.2 por pi bueno
tal vez no sea lo más fácil de este
mundo pero inclusive ya lo puedes dejar
así que decir que esta es una buena
aproximación pues su dado caso creo que
es mucho más fácil poner esto en la
calculadora pero es hora de comprobar mi
respuesta que es 2 pib que multiplica a
x menos 2 así que vamos a sacar aquí a
nuestra pantalla original y para eso la
voy a tener justo aquí y es hora de
comprobar mi respuesta ok voy a apretar
esto y de lujo estamos bien